bonjour à toutes et à tous ceux bonjour
federica bonjour j mee bonjour marinette
torpilles
bonjour bonjour aux auditeurs et
auditrices de martinique la première
conseillère territoriale exécutive
chargée du développement économique de
l'emploi et des aides aux entreprises
c'est ce dernier aspect qui nous
intéressera plus particulièrement ce
matin marine et de torpilles puisque
vous êtes la présidente de martinique
développement mais aussi d'initiatives
martinique active
quelle est la différence entre enfin la
différence et peut-être même la
complémentarité entre ces deux
organismes ces deux structures
c'est d'abord la complémentarité ce sont
deux organistes deux outils à
disposition des entreprises donc qui
sont donc nous sommes des outils mais
des satellites de la ctn au niveau de
martine développement nous faisons de
l'accompagnement au niveau des chefs
d'entreprise et des porteurs de projets
c'est surtout de l'information leur dire
tous les dispositifs qui existent sur le
territoire pour qu'ils puissent mieux
ensuite voir au niveau des partenaires
comment arriver à bien développer leurs
projets nous faisons aussi des
événements attractifs comme le salon aux
qui est le salon de l'entrepreneuriat
nous faisons de la menacer sa survie
vers la tunique développe initiative et
que initiative martin qu'actif c'est
notre outil de financement
donc au niveau d'initiative martinique
nous faisons des prêts à taux zéro aux
porteurs de projets et aux chefs
d'entreprises donc qui ont un projet de
développement
et puis nous faisons aussi de la
garantie des prêts bancaires
donc c'est mais nous sommes en fin de
compte que ce soit sur martine
développement aux initiatives matinée
nous adressons ou même public c'est à
dire des tpe est vraiment des petites
entreprises alors avec initiative
martinique justement initiative
martinique active marine et de torpilles
vous voici en quelque sorte de plus en
plus en images en tout cas en
représentation de bonnes fées de
marennes sympa quoi justement de nos
petits et très petit entrepreneur mais
oui avec ce club lancé il y à peine
quelques jours c'était la semaine
dernière donc un club des entrepreneurs
de tpe alors il est il est et ce qui a
été lancée c'est la nouvelle animation
du club parce que le club existe depuis
2007 voilà c'est ça oui c'est un projet
ni si en 2016 il ya même eu une sorte
d'expérimentation depuis ses trois ans à
faire vous savez quand nous faisons
quand nous faisons les prêts là au
niveau de notre tête de réseau puisque
nous avons nous sommes affiliés à
initiative france et dans notre cahier
des charges nous avons l'obligation de
suivre nos des prêteurs enfin les
personnes à qui des bénéficiaires des
prêts et donc nous avons deux outils que
nous aussi que nous mettons à leur
disposition c'est le club départ un tas
dire des parrains c'est un acte
volontaire de vouloir voir un parent qui
les accompagne dans leur développement
et puis il ya le club des entrepreneurs
donc tous ceux qui bénéficient d'un prêt
donc peuvent faire peuvent entrer dans
ce club
et là nous avons de l'animation et
surtout ce sont nous mutualisons les
bonnes pratiques
c'est une synergie qui mise en place une
dynamique des ateliers sont proposés
aussi selon les thèmes que certains
proposent donc c'est vraiment je dirais
un an de un espace auquel on fait du
réseautage aussi voilà du réseautage
donc vous avez relancé un petit peu en
aval manière tout à fait tout à fait
gavin
mais l'objectif reste le même c'est
favoriser la pérennité des entreprises
exactement notamment des petites et très
petites entreprises qui chez nous dès
fois vivent pas longtemps
malheureusement tout à fait c'est
exactement ça c'est à dire que
effectivement ce club donc comme je
voulais dire existait depuis 2007 et là
nous avons revu l'animation donc nous
avons un nouvel animateur
parce que quel que soit je dirais le
groupe que vous avez il faut le faire
vivre
il faut lui donner je dirais des
objectifs et c'est ce que nous avons
fait là avec un nouvelle année
acteur pour ce club pour que les
entreprises bénéficiaires de nos prêts
surtout le second dit le chef
d'entreprise une certaine solitude quand
il est face à ces décisions face à son
exploitation
et là ils ont des moments des changes
des moments de cohésion qui leur
permettent d'échanger de devoir en sorte
le judas les difficultés des uns et des
autres et puis comme ça de s'appuyer
pour avoir des coups certains conseils
ou savoir ce que fait l'autre y voir
qu'on n'est pas seuls dans la difficulté
de manière pratique un entrepreneur donc
comment il fait pour justement devenir
membre de ce club
adhérer à ce club est ce que ça coûte
cher et ce qu'il faut montrer un certain
nombre de critères bon voilà pas du tout
le club et il est gratuit
si tu es vraiment un espace gratuit qui
est à la disposition des bénéficiaires
des prêts donc quelqu'un qui a eu un
prêt à l'initiative martinique
donc peut intégrer le club des
entrepreneurs et s'est essayée
l'ensemble de ces deux nouveaux
bénéficiaires qui forment ce club et
c'est vraiment une obligation que nous
avons dans le process que nous
développons puisqu'aujourd'hui
initiative martinique active qui est une
structure qui a été mise en place depuis
le depuis à l'époque du président marie
jeanne et qui a été longtemps présidé
par daniel marie-sainte et aujourd'hui
donc une structure que nous avons là que
nous avons voulu relancer relancer et
redynamiser pour faire en sorte qu' elle
soit vraiment je dirais qu'elles
répondent aux besoins d'aidé des
porteurs de projets et des chefs
d'entreprises tu travailler en réseau
c'est facile en martinique dans dans un
petit territoire ont quelque fois belle
et les chefs d'entreprises y compris
quand elles sont petites ou très petites
peuvent se retrouver même pas forcément
concurrence directe mais vous voyez ce
que je veux dire voilà ils peuvent être
victimes alors on prend qui sait c'est
vrai on apprend aux savez c'est comme
danser comme dans d'autres je pense dans
d'autres milieux
vrai qu'on a tendance à rester à être
individualiste et et quoique on va
peut-être vous voulez une idée vous
voulez une pratique et là parfois comme
ça je peux dire c'est là dans le club
vous êtes on est vraiment je dirais dans
un dans un moment de partage et c'est
vrai que quel que soit si vous montez un
groupe et vous ne l'animé passe si vous
ne donnez pas d objectif c'est pour ça
que dans le club il y à des ateliers sur
qui sont décidés ou les sujets sont
décidés par les bénéficiaires c'est à
dire que effectivement peut-être que il
y en a un qui peut dire j'aurais aimé
savoir un peu qu'est ce que c'est par
exemple ailleurs j tout le monde en
parle de cette récupération et cette
gestion des données qui est toujours
d'une obligation
qu'est ce qu'il en est c'est vrai que le
chef d'entreprise à ce moment là quand
ils demandent par exemple ce thème à ce
moment là on regarde si on peut
effectivement lui faire un atelier sur
ce thème donc c'est sais je dirais c'est
l'outil qui à disposition des
bénéficiaires qui en fin de compte
animer selon la la volonté des
bénéficiaires mais pour cela nous avons
donc mis un animateur professionnel qui
est là qui doit coordonner et faire
vivre le groupe
et puis y'a une par exemple nous avons
grâce au club par exemple au salon de
l'habitat l'année dernière et nous
allons recommencer cette année
certainement nous avons pris deux stands
et nous avons pu faire que nous tpe
puisse celles qui étaient intéressés
donc puisse être au niveau du stand donc
elle n'hésitait pas là tout pendant
toute la semaine mais tous les deux
jours omar exposition d'un va tourner et
sa place a permis à plusieurs petites
entreprises de se trouver là alors que
toute seule elle aurait pas pu être au
salon de l'habitat
donc ce sont vraiment des des opérations
de ce type où la mutualisation est un
est un vrai plus pour les entreprises à
la marine et de torpilles conseillère
territoriale exécutive
on part des aides aux entreprises et de
ce point de vue
martinique développement que vous
présidez aussi à signer une convention
de partenariat avec l'ordre des experts
comptables
il y a deux ans l'objectif faciliter
l'accès aux expertises pour les tpe
notamment les très petites entreprises
dites orphelines tout alors ça veut dire
quoi dites orphelines c'est des
entreprises en phase de création où
donald le développement non c'est pas ça
dans des entreprises 100 experts
comptables tout simplement pas d'expert
comptable et féline ses fils michael est
l'expert comptable et vraiment je dirais
pas un parent proche de l'entreprise
oui alors justement ça fonctionne depuis
deux ans avec cette convention de
partenariat oui oui tout à fait et
j'aime j'aime à dire que c'est l'une des
des initiatives enfin d'une des actions
en martinique de ces entreprises
orpheline qui n'ont pas goûté mais
surtout dans les petites et les très
petites entreprises
je ne dévoilerai rien de dire que
beaucoup d'entreprises ont des
comptables entre guillemets marron et l
noël ne rentre pas dans je dirais dans
la dans la réglementation et la
procédure normale et donc ce que je
voulais dire c'est que c'est vraiment
l'une des actions que je que j'ai menée
avec martine développement dont je suis
la plus fière parce que je pense que là
nous avons vraiment apporté jeudi un
dispositif mais utile et nécessaire à la
petit temps mais ça vous coûte quand
même parce que il ya une prise en charge
partielle sur trois ans des honoraires
d'expertise-comptable en guise en scène
donc c'est vraiment une réduction à 6
citations pour les inouk à toute
procédure que l'entreprise doit doit
suivre
mais avec cette procédure elle apprend
je dirais à organiser sa comptabilité et
sa comptabilité est saisi par un expert
comptable qu'elle prend que mais que
nous avons que nous chapiteau et que
nous que nous regardons avec pour
qu'elles puissent faire les travaux et
l'expert comptable à la fin qui est
désigné par l'entreprise puisqu'elle
choisi l'expert-comptable sur une liste
que nous avons qui était donné par
l'ordre des experts comptables
elle choisit leur expert-comptable qui
sort en fin d'exercice les comptes de
bilan
deux résultats vraiment ce dispositif
globalement ça nous coûte mais ça coûte
à l'entreprise en moyenne je dirais 80
80 euros par mois pour avoir en finale
de compte
un expert comptable avec des contes et
des comptes de résultats et de bilan
sortie régulièrement une entreprise
tentait là ça demain quand elle veut
faire un prêt et que la banque lui
demande c'est ces éléments comptables
elle peut les donner elle est je dirais
elle est tranquille à ce niveau là et
nous comme on la suit sur la sur cette
partie qui quitteraient très importante
dans son entreprise
elle peut le chef d'entreprise peut se
consacrer à son coeur de métier puisque
sur 7 sur la partie administratif
on les aide dans les accompagnent et en
fait en sorte que ça ne leur coûte pas
autant que ça devrait leur coûter les
experts-comptables un effort sur
l'horaire vraiment un évent très très
substantielle et kiki vraiment une
réussite pour nous et nous aussi nous
accompagnons dans le paiement des
honoraires
voilà alors marionnettes torpille tout
ça n'est peut-être pas complètement non
plus désintéressée parce que vous êtes
une femme politique que vous êtes une
élue donc vous faites de la politique on
a l'impression quand même que c'était de
se se brossage dans le sens du poil du
monde des entreprises c'est un enjeu
politicien y compris entre vous même
dans le camp de yan monplaisir voilà
deux maps ayant chance y'a pas longtemps
il ya une joute vous étiez entre
d'ailleurs pris dans cette partie de
ping pong entre yan monplaisir et et
miguel laventure notamment autour de ces
fonds jérémy vous savez le nom de
certaines jérémy pour jones européen
louis source forme micro taux médian oms
ait enterprise bref j'avais laissé sont
des fonds européens destinés aux
entreprises et il ya eu 7 7 passes
d'armes verbales là
dans un milieu alors d'abord je ne mange
au combat maintenant non non je ne
bronze pas ce qu'on me dit je fais ça
avec des vues politiques non j'ai été
nommé président de martine développement
et d'initiatives martinez que par le par
le président alfred marie-jeanne et j'ai
une mission
donc j'ai accompli déjà ma mission qu'on
vous donne une mission vous devez la
faire et donc je l'accomplis et c'est
vrai que quand je suis investi je suis
engagé je ne suis pas en demi mesure
donc je fais un maximum pour pouvoir
aider notamment la petite entreprise
parce que si c est l on sait ça le but
elles ont un besoin qui quand même
essentiel et 70% de notre écosystème est
formé de tpe de pe donc aujourd'hui j'ai
essayé de répondre à ceux à leur besoin
de voir ce qui ce qu'il leur fallait
pour mouvoir avoir un développement
serein pour pouvoir aussi et si tu es
d'accord ce soir moment et tant pis ça
peut faciliter quelques veaux et non
mais attendez si je suis artiste la
chaleur par exemple ya beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise qui fait liste il vota je
ne sais pas vous serez certainement
candidat c'est sympa et et la mort mon
but c'est le but c'était de remplir la
mission qui m'était donné et je les jeux
et je pense que je le fais le cap le
fond sur un visa s'est réglée alors nous
reste plus qu'à 30 secondes oui le fond
j'ai réglé entre miguel laventure et yan
monplaisir et le wii wheel sont gérés
mais nous y travaillons et nous pensons
pouvoir sortir ce fonds d'ici l'année
2020 a dit au milieu des années 2020
parce qu'il ya des procédures qui sont
lourdes et puis avec des appels des
appels d'offres pour des sociétés de
gestion
c'est assez compliqué le montage mais
d'ici mai 2000 merci on sera au rendez
vous est pris rendez vous inscrire merci
val d'or